Narrator: Rick and Steve
had no idea
what type of bones,
they were looking at.
But, they
seemed intriguing.
They took pictures and decided
to show them to Pedro.
Pedro: So, needless to say,
I called Professor Berger.
He didn't answer his
phone and we decided
we're going to drive
to his house.
Because now we're all
excited, bubbling, of course.
Pedro: Arriving at his home
I rung the bell and when he
answered, my words to him was
"Lee, you really
want to talk to us."
( laughs )
Lee: I knew immediately that
that was a Fossil Hominid.
It was not a human.
I could tell by the
proportions of the teeth
I could tell by its size.
You can see that fine
scientific scale
that I'm lucky, we have
not got in trouble for.
Because if you read carefully,
it says, "Home Sewing Aid Only"
on the side of it.
( laughs )
But I could see, that this
was something...
extraordinary.
Second to that, it was just
lying there on the ground.
Now, that doesn't happen
in South Africa.
I assure you, it doesn't
happen in South Africa.
That skull that you saw
that Matthew had found in
that hard rock
that rock is like concrete.
That skull and skeleton
just one of them took about
22,000 preparation hours
to get to that state.
This is lying there.
The next picture confirmed
that this was something
truly extraordinary.
Every one of those bones,
I realized was Hominid.
Believe me, they are.
Anyone trained from me would
look at that and say, "My Gosh!"
And they're just
lying there in dirt.
Even more extraordinary,
there was a skull.
Can you see the curvature there?
Just sitting in dirt,
on a floor.
And it looked tiny.
So, I decided I needed
to put someone in there
that I absolutely trusted.
That could take a scientific
photograph of these things.
And I happened to know someone,
who fit
the physiological profile
that could get down that cave.
Who I trusted immensely my,
then six foot four...
son
who's sitting in the
audience today.
Who is
physiologically appropriate
to get down a
seven and a half inch slot.
Showed him how to use a
scientific camera
gave him a scale and...
a few days later...
We went into this cave,
a torturous route
that took us almost 50 minutes
to get to the base
of Dragon's Back.
Up we went, up this thing, where
if you slip off, you die.
We get to the edge of that
crevice and we look down it
and... down I sent Matthew
with Rick and Steve.
Because I'm trying for
"Father of the Year".
( audience laughter )
There I sat in the dark
looking at this
impossible route.
How in the world was I
going to accomplish
an expedition
and excavation here?
Forty five minutes or so go
by and I hear scrabbling.
Matthew's head pops up.
Because I'm going for
"Father of the Year"
I didn't go, "Are you okay?".
I went, "And?"
( audience laughter )
And Matthew handed me
the camera and said
"Daddy...
it's amazing, It's beautiful."
It was everything that those
original pictures had said
and that's when I knew I
had to push the button.
Except, I didn't know
what button to push.
'Cause I needed people
to work in there.
I needed people to...
effectively risk their lives
in a well-known cave
down a seven and a half
inch slot, underground.
In a fragile, relatively
shallow environment
that could have gases in it.
It could collapse at any time.
I had no idea how I was gonna
find people with skills.
They had to be
paleoanthropologists
or archeologists,
they had to be able to excavate
they had to have climbing
skills, all these things.
I did what any one
of you would do...
I put a Facebook Ad out.
( audience laughter )
That Facebook Ad asked
for skinny scientists.
They had to be able to work
in underground environments
climbing skills,
not claustrophobic.
They wouldn't tell them
what to do.
They had to drop everything
be ready within
three weeks from that date
to come for a month
to South Africa.
I wasn't going to pay you.
Oh and by the way, you have
to have a PhD or a Masters
in paleoanthopology,
archeology, etc.
Hit send,
thinking there were probably
three people in the world
that would fit that.
Within 10 days, I had almost
60 qualified applicants.
Eighty percent of which
were young women.
I selected from that,
six extraordinary scientists
who just happened
to be young women.
These extraordinary scientists,
dropped everything
and flew to South Africa
within three weeks.
We'd put together a
60 person expedition.
All the support teams you need,
the safety cavers
planning this extensive
underground expedition.
At the same time, this great
society took another risk.
They agreed to do this
live to the world.
Because I thought, this may be
the last moment in history
where we actually
can bring the world
the recovery of
a Fossil Hominid skeleton.
And so, they let us create
this blog and website
all ready to tweet
and Facebook and blog
and go live on the day
we went underground.
A very brave move, by the way.
Because, if I was wrong
this was going to be a
rather large embarrassment.
On November the seventh,
that 60 team expedition
launched in the field.
Over the next couple of days
we laid three and
a half kilometers
of military grade
audio-visual cables.
Cameras, all the machinery
that we would need
to conduct this excavation,
live underground.
We would create
Command Centers, Caving Tents
a Science Tent to take
this skeleton out
live in front of the world.
On November 10th, we launched
the Rising Star Expedition.
There, we sent those
scientists into this cave
led initially by Matthew.
And we watched these
amazing images.
Very quickly,
these amazing scientists
became known as
"Underground Astronauts".
And yes, I have received
enough hate mail
about why they shouldn't
be called, "Astronauts".
They should be called,
"Terranauts" or "Troglonauts" or
some other version of
that and I apologize.
But, I'm not that sorry,
because it really was
like watching astronauts
on a spacewalk.
They would get up in the
safety gear, helmets on
all this stuff and equipment
and they would vanish
from our sights.
And they would appear in
these black and white images
as they crawled through
these cave systems.
Taking often 40-45 minutes
to get to that chute
and then they would vanish
from our communications
as they went down this slot
where they could wear no safety
gear, 'cause it's so tight.
And they began to
excavate material.
And these are the kind of
images that we were watching.
I could communicate
live with them.
They couldn't see me,
but I could talk to them.
The collection began,
we designed technology
that had never been used
before, underground.
White light, laser scanners
that were giving us real time
scans on computers like that
down to resolutions of
0.3 of a millimeter
as we were mapping underground
with these scanners.
It was amazing!
And material began to come out.
And by the second day,
we realized, I had been wrong.
It was not a skeleton.
It was...
more than one skeleton.
By day two,
we had three right femurs.
I assure you, there is
no primate in the world
that has three right legs.
As we would go, by the
end of the first week
we had discovered more
Fossil Hominid material
than in the richest
site ever discovered
in the search for human
origins in Southern Africa.
In one week.
And I could see that site,
right out my command center
because it was less
than a mile away.